[Music]
thank you for joining this talk I'm very
happy to present here at pator and yeah
let's start so I hope this going to work
yeah I have a slide about me so that you
have an idea who standing here um so I
am found of jool and IO that's kind of
the key thing which now like to spread
and yeah this next to that I I worked in
data science like since it's feeling
like always from my start into
University and it's in total more than
10 years by now and I've been working
Consulting like more than five years
these are kind of two numbers and
because we here also about tools so
these are my favorite tools I use binder
a lot and I'm very sad that it got yeah
sized down recently um Jupiter I'm
working on on NYX OS and like it it's a
bit tricky here and there but it's
really cool I'm working a lot with
kubernetes these days and clouds uh with
web tools because yeah everyone needs
web tools and actually also Julia so I
can also recommend you joining
tomorrow's Julia
con and if you want to reach out to me
kind of between the this um the chairs
philosophy of mine is one of my favorite
so and if you also like this question
what does it need for a machine to
become conscious just reach out I I love
to discuss hours and hours about this
topic okay so what we I need to find
yeah what we going to see
today engineer yeah this this side this
side okay okay okay so I'm going to uh
introduce you reactive notebooks so it's
kind of was my work over the last month
actually to get this working for python
it's really Premier presentation so we
have as just Basics I want to go through
user
inputs um which is kind of the key
spirit I think that's the main Spirit of
reactive notebooks that you can just
replace whatever thing you want with the
user
input and an awesome feature which but
less kind of yeah that's generic self
updates um then I have a couple of um
complete examples and finally little
note on installing packages I have a
talk later on about the deployment part
which was already mentioned which is
more part of the Jolan business um
there's a talk presenting Jolan IO um in
two hours and I won't speak too much
about the deployment part now but if you
have time we I also have kind of an
attachment slide and I can go to that
too but I think time is rushing uh so
I'm focusing on the reactive notebook
itself and presenting its
features okay yeah it's really working
there okay let's go to reactive
notebooks so this is uh a kind of live
demo but because live demos were not
allowed it's all taken on video so we
have a lot of videos which we go through
and now I play the first so when come to
the basics of this notebook so what you
see is that we have cells which are yeah
like like in Jupiter we can execute them
and they have outputs and now comes the
first surprise bam wow the outputs on
top uh okay so many who use Jupiter they
they prefer the Out book below and they
build a little hel to actually switch
this but this notebook just comes um
because of design decisions uh with the
output on top be so yeah as this initial
um configuration so we can change this
later on but I keep it with the default
now so that you get the spirit of this
so and the key thing what we now do here
is we we make a little
computation and uh what this computation
results and you will see in a second um
and the part which is kind of most
important so it it always tells you kind
of um errors like normal in the cell
yeah and the key part is now that it is
reactive so every time you change
something all the rest will be
reevaluated and the thing was already
reactivity so we imported SE uh square
root from math and it all automatically
re-evaluated the cell which depended on
square root so this was already um um
yeah
reactivity and we can also now change n
again and everything else will update
and which is kind of a key part also of
the spirit is that we don't have a
distinction between mark down cells and
um code cells but this is really all the
same and this yeah gives you the feeling
of okay everything is reactive yeah also
my my output is reactive my my
documentation my self documentation is
reactive and this little example is
indeed Computing Pi which is lovely I
took it from the um documentation of the
Julia version of this reactive notebook
called Pluto and adapted it to the
python world
and we go through this example in
another slide so not what we can do also
is that in every cell we can hide the
input this makes a lot of sense for
documentation outputs yeah because you
always don't want you don't want to see
the marked on code you only want to see
the HTML
part and yeah and this kind of super
simple but we can also hide the the
input of all the other cells so it's
really um a simplified version in a
sense yeah we only have one type of code
cell so and after all my typing this of
course takes even longer if you record
this yeah so um we we finally will see
some some reactivity on on the on the
end so we are now just interpolating uh
stuff into our markdown which works I
did a lot of work for for this to to
make sure everything works and we can
now see it and the final part so just
changing
stuff is going to re-evaluate the rest
and yeah so
now you can kind of play with it back
and forth and I hope you get the spirit
of of the basics so let me check if I
forgot something so we have automatic
dependency tracking which makes sure
that only the sales are executed would
actually need to be executed so it's not
always running everything but it's
really only running what really needs to
be
run
um yeah okay that's that was that have
been the basics so I was actually um uh
checking it's fine if we take some
questions meanwhile as well I just need
to make sure I repeat the question so
please feel welcome to to raise your
voice or ask a question this would be
the first point where I think okay might
be a good CH place to already ask a
question someone yeah
please thank you thank you very much for
this question I was expecting it so the
question is whether the order um output
on the top input on the bottom is
actually enforced and the answer is no
it's not and I'm not sure I think I have
an example later on but you can actually
build a super tiny extension which is
just another piece of code which you
execute in in a Cell which interacts
with the layout and then it changes and
then if you delete the cell again it
switches back to the default old version
so you can build such tiny extensions
which also extend the
layout and yeah I've done this
already um uh as as an introductory
example yeah thank you for the question
I'll go on then yeah this this
way okay so next part uh wait graphical
user input
one so now comes the key part to to get
you the feeling of how how powerful this
is so let's hope the video is playing as
well it's a
bit
no yeah no okay there we go so okay what
we see right now is that the order of
the cells actually doesn't matter so you
can move them around as you want
dependency tracking is there to to make
sure everything is in the right order
and what we are now focusing on is that
you can replace variables with um user
input and we are now importing from
Julia call the main package sjl that's
kind of the usual way to import Julia
this is because the um the pl The
Notebook called Pluto notebook actually
is or originally from the Julia language
and hooking into it the easiest way to
get the UI elements is just to reuse the
existing
mechanism but in principle uh we can
also support IPython Widgets or the like
it's just um yeah it just needs a bit of
work and as written out if you like to
help me I I really welcome help so if
you if you're curious about this and
want IPython widgets to work here um
yeah uh reach out to me and we I can
give you access to resources so that you
can experiment so what you see here is a
a little um user input which is called a
scrubbable imported from plut Pluto UI
package we're going to see on the next
slide what what other possibilities are
there you also have seen kind of autoc
completion and yeah and all this works
and now we want to make our scrubbable
kind of to to replace our n hence uh I
was building with lock space um some
some integers and we can input them into
the scrubbable and now we have kind of
the same UI element which reaches uh
yeah from one to
um 10 the^ of 7 and now comes the key
part now we can easily replace our
definition with this input and this kind
of makes so I'm uncommenting the N
because of type dependency tracking
there should always only be one
definition of n apparently otherwise it
doesn't know where it comes from and now
we bind it this is kind of the special
magic function um this is yeah you just
need to remember that special
functionality bind will actually Define
the n and make it react on this UI input
and then we can also include it into our
markdown this was actually super uh bit
more work than I was hoping for so what
I need to add is a special syntax these
I'm not sure whether you ever seen this
fragments so like an HTML teag without
an actually Tech and I I like the syntax
it's very smooth and with this yeah I
have kind of a support of inline HTML
which is a little extension of standard
markdown which does not support it and
you see that we now exchanged our n by
this user input and everything else
works the same this the spirit yeah it's
just the very same as before just
exchanging some manual input by some
graphical user
interface and yeah so in another summary
thanks to reactivity this just gets a
dashboard yeah so this this is like cool
thing about um reactive
notebooks okay it was the second part um
I think I I get the next slide as well
before again asking for some questions
so this is um second slide just an
overview over all the interactivity
which is already there um hooked in from
the Julia side and it should
start yeah now the video is also playing
so we have sliders yeah so which just
update we have um so the syntax is
slightly different because this is not
Julia we have the scrubble which we just
used number field and um check boxes so
there's really support for all the
standard Parts text fields
and and also which is not here on this
list actually webcam input and all this
so you really just have the full HTML
world to your feed you can use whatever
you want and yeah and to the best of my
research we can also make ipon widgets
work it just needs a little um wrapper
to to confirm um the the event system
which is used by by this reactive
notebook file picker which which gives
you an awesome idea yeah you can use
this notebook just to to upload an image
or PDF and automatically trigger
analysis and you had also download
buttons so you can really make
this yeah like a like a website yeah so
this is this is really plainly notebook
but than reactivity it's also a website
if you want yeah and of course videos
and all all the
stuff okay um are there some is there
some further question good point to get
the question
in if not um I'm moving on to the next
power feature so this is kind of the key
feature I think yeah so this is really
this which which captures the spirit of
react and reactive notebook and it also
comes well together with the point that
there's only one type of cell so it's
it's not like you have kind of this
distinction but because of this
reactivity really kind of can merge your
documentation your your layout kind of
together with your code that's one
question thank you so much so the
question is to repeat um whether there
is an um yeah a display mechanism to to
only interact with the slider so the
interaction part which is intended yeah
and not change the code and this is
indeed kind of one of the ideas of which
I realized in jool and iio where you
have the
deployment um yeah and there's also kind
of um there are different kinds of
deployments so you can actually also
deploy this as a Plaine file server
re-rendering Al so pre-rendering sorry
pre-rendering all the different
combinations yeah and get out the um the
python core completely yeah so that you
really only have a web side which then
naturally is only interactable by
sliders so this is one way and I also
build kind of another way because of the
next feature um which self updates that
you actually would need a running Python
and I also built the thing around there
so that you you still have this um I say
production view yeah so that you really
see your website as a viewer and not as
a
developer thank you for the question
it's a really good really good
question
okay qu of an hour left half time
and yeah then let's look to the self
updates part so this is a cool thing
which um delivers the the real time
process um so we we already saw this
actually now a stupid example we saw
this inputs and I I just have a little
addition on top so that you get an idea
um um so this is not extending the basil
problem but um nevertheless so what we
import now uh some some dates
functionality from from the Julia side
and we import another package of mine
this a Jolan
Pluto which um yeah has a couple of
helper function um to to get an easy
kind of access to to these
features and the first feature I want to
show you is actually from the question
from the first question the output part
so there's a special haer called output
Below in this package and magically
bam the output is below and we can
delete the cell the output is SC above
and because I myself also preferred
below I'm again putting it in and have
the output below
then and yeah so I I admit this is also
my preferred uh style I use it all the
time so and this same package gives a
couple of other helpers which also not
give these um self updates features and
here we I could in principle alsoo
support python daytime it's just uh as
of now it's really kind of um yeah
Premier fresh I'm still using the Julia
um dates
format um but as you see it's super
simple to support kind of the Julia uh
dates format and you see also Julia has
awesome yeah algebra support or What's
this called called you can work with
dates in a very intuitive way we we take
kind of a seal of the current date round
it to the next two seconds up and what
you see
now I guess the video is already over I
hope you saw it it was self
updating yeah it's already over I I I
missed it I hope you you haven't missed
it
um yeah I have another example which
gives this a bit more a bigger feature
so this is the very same idea now yeah
so we exchanged a manual input before
with the user um interface input and now
we exchange a manual input with a server
side trigger so to say yeah so we have
client side triggers and we have server
side triggers and this just go can go
together and yeah and I go on to the
next example to illustrate this in a bit
I more ways I have a little break for
myself so um I like
XKCD arts and um I I actually like this
especially and yeah I hope you can
appreciate as well so it's it's really
good to have the right tools yeah and
and paper is an awesome tool
yeah so of course you can't do this with
a with the reactive notebook but uh it's
it's still a great
analogy okay
so stream example this is a full little
tiny demo for for giving the self
updates and um this comes kind of with
the examples from um cloud. jolen
doio if you go there and log in with
GitHub um and create an empty
environment you get these example
notebooks which give you kind of an
introduction to to the features and you
see um yeah Julia Python and R are there
supported and today we're focusing on R
so let's uh start this video Yeah works
okay so we going to the streams um
example and it's already started and
running and we we have some um summary
on the top so we actually have a table
of contents feature also which is which
just there a plute UI feature and I
built some little UI inputs which can
change the the shift you see immediately
what shift means in this context so we
we're generating some um time serious
data random walk also called and we can
just change this and this is a kind of
as a summary just and we we have some
code we import our
tools um import Q threading for for the
self update support as a little demo a
DQ um we create now kind of the we the
part we create updates so initializing
the que and having a little
thread um which always puts elements
into the queue just normal yeah a
threaded queue we use in Python and then
we can fetch the updates and now there's
a special function Jolan pluto. repeat
qg get so this I I support it because
it's key Q as the yeah as the interface
and then things update automatically
every time something new comes we have
the UI part yeah we we can build them uh
separately but we can also combine them
into some markdown table yeah which
we've been using at the top um we have
also a plot which is now just kind of
just met plot lip and that was it so
that was bit quick but I hope the
preparation before was
um was okay to to get you an idea so
this is just kind of a super tiny uh
demo yeah so you in real life you
would a yeah what I I want to show you
is that here above we have a just the
summary yeah we we repeat the um the the
input elements and we repeat the figure
and just on top so bam we have a summary
uh at the top and yeah it's really very
straightforward very simple and in
general I like this approach like having
a summary on top yeah some
other sections um and also how it's
implemented section yeah implementation
detail section so of course you could
build dashboard which hides all the
other things yeah you actually don't
need to press hide on everything you can
also have a a view which only focuses on
certain cells this also possible but I
appreciate actually having this yeah
within the the result yeah to have a
something which shares also the
implementation detail yeah I I
appreciate this knowledge sharing part
of it so you give a summary at the top
with all the key information yeah for
controllers for managers whoever but
then you still leave the implementation
details below yeah and if someone is
interested you can kind of look into it
and and this is really yeah an easygoing
open spirit with one yeah notebook which
summarizes it
all and yeah I I really like this way
and and what's also cool about this
maybe you already realized this this is
mobile friend
yeah so this is linear it's intended
kind of also for for on mobile and you
can actually go to cloud. ja.io also of
your mobile device yeah log in there and
use it it's in a sense one of the first
really working coding environments on
mobile but of course you don't need it
for development necessarily you can also
just need take it for for viewing yeah
and I appreciate also this you you're
used to 2D dashboards yeah
but I I think this is worth to
rethinking wor to Worth to rethink it so
that a more linear style of thing just
better fits our world today especially
in a mobile sense you can still get um
yeah wide dashboards you can also stack
things next to to each other that's also
possible you can also still use this
with the reactivity um but I appreciate
this linear style it's just yeah simpler
and yeah makes a lot of
sense um this updates I wanted to add um
you can read of course of any event
system Q system yeah so in principle
also uh Kafka or uh red Pander uh
Kinesis
so this doesn't have to be a pyo random
number generator but can be a real
system where you get updates from and
and just you yeah by this you have a a
stream stream processing you write it
back to another queue you write it back
to an event system I'm mainly on AWS so
yeah simple Q service is yeah super
easily integrated just yeah bam it's
there and on Jolan IO um there's also
kind of this yeah you need to authorize
your
notebook this key thing is also taken
care of if you like uh to to users in
your company um these things are out
there okay another five minutes but are
there because this key feature are there
questions to this safe
updates
please
yeah cells get upd what
if upates amount of
awesome question so the question is how
to work with uh cells which run for a
significant amount of time and thereby
will block your workflow when always run
on reactive
triggers and and yes you can do both so
you have the possibility to to have an
interrupt you see kind of if it's
running a clock increases or it's
running for this amount of time and
there you can direct IR ly kind of
hit uh kill
it
um yeah and the second part is even more
powerful yeah you can disable it and
this took me actually quite a while the
the S updates have different flavors and
the naive way or the first way which
which I've stumbled upon was actually
not working well with this disabling so
in principle you can actually um a cell
has a a three um three dots where you
have a little menu and you can disable
the cell and it will disable all the
dependencies and and I actually made
sure that also the save updates are
working with it because there's some
server side logic going on so if you
change something on the client UI part
doesn't necessarily work well with the
server side part so it actually in the
first implementation it still went on
and you had this problem but I made sure
that also the self updates if you
disable the cell it's running one last
time and then it
stops and so you have real flexible way
or of switching between the re real
process realtime process um way or kind
of yeah stopping it experimenting with
further changing but here and there so
this is yeah this is there and super
flexible thank you for the
question okay uh so then let's go on we
have a couple of minutes left yeah I
just want to show you um just for the
completeness of course you can build
dashboards and this is just a tiny c um
CO2 uh
plot um doesn't fit on this screen here
and I yeah I was cutting it but of
course there's also an xais label yeah I
I always put an ex excess label on my
plots
and and this just yeah a plotly example
yeah so um met plot lip put through the
plotly converter already works out of
the box and you have a nice interactive
HTML plot as well and yeah and what we
see is that the Netherlands have been
doing better than Germany for quite a
while but um
yeah yeah it's now on on the same scale
and of course all on a bad scale
yeah um yeah so key thing I I wrote here
on the left plot lead tools um met plot
lip to plotly this just what's used here
and then you have the also the
interactive HTML plot which are always
awesome for for dashboarding
things and we we combine kind of now of
course the um the reactive notebook part
yeah having this input interfaces with a
plotly interaction so this is yeah
easygoing and super
intuitive okay so installing packages oh
one minute left but we have five more
minutes for further questions so I just
want to make to show you kind of the
last key feature you remember our
outline
um package installation is handled
automatically so you just start up your
notebook and you import thing and things
are imported for you like
installed and this is done by by cond in
the background and thanks to cond this
actually is also really smooth because
it has prepackaged
binaries and yeah and we can hide the
logs have you seen this it's also there
was also the disabling feature on the on
the same menu and yeah and we can uh do
further stuff with nay and yeah this is
kind of also a spirit of this reactivity
from the Julia side this automatic
package
handling and yep
okay so future plan I want to support
okay whoa I we have five minutes for
questions and because we took questions
I can kind of made it a bit flexible so
I want to support ppar clusters because
um the set up on on cloud. Jolan o is
kubernetes based and should be able to
just integrate a cluster which you
control from this reactive notebook
array cluster as well and I also would
like to see ipon which is support and if
anyone would like to help me on this I'm
more than happy to yeah to get you on
and and get your
help okay so
summary okay so let's make it quick so
we saw reactive notebook you can use it
for experiment just experimentation it's
this um reactivity gives you a cool feel
of just experimenting everything else is
updated you have this dashboard by just
replacing manual inputs with UI elements
you can transform events with the self
updates yeah have kind of a stream uh a
realtime process and hopefully in the
future you can also transform big data
but just spawning a whole cluster from
your little reactivity notebook interact
with the cluster and destroy the cluster
again and just kind of yeah all from one
script that's the plan and then cloud.
jan. I haven't spoken too much about it
this is kind of the place where you can
test this right now
um uh there it's kind of a hosted
reactive notebook service you can
collaborate and you have def test prod
automation more later on in in the talk
about um jool and
IO yeah I hope hope you got this joke if
not it's not so
important but the time is uh tiny okay
so we have couple of more minutes for
further question thank you very much for
for being my guest
today please so the order of cells
doesn't because dependencies are
inferred what if I Define is one and N
is in different cells yeah so the
question is um uh what is with if one
variable is defined multiple times
and and then an error will be thrown
actually so it will tell you stupid you
should Define n only once and
then
yeah and yeah so sometimes you actually
want this and if you if you want to kind
of um mutate something update something
yeah so what you do is to to build um a
container yeah which is not recognized
as a normal definition if you just make
a equals two yeah that's interpret as
the definition but if you have a equals
um list of one element yeah and you
update this this one element then it
won't
complain so and this was actually also
used we have this plot yeah with this
random uh work and this was a d DQ DQ I
don't know how to pronounce it yeah and
and this is just a list so we append
something yeah and it updates itself and
we had a cell which in initializes this
yeah but this is not triggered again
yeah the dependency trigging will skip
this because it's not depending on the
update the update only pushes in it into
into the collection and and because it's
of a fixed maximum size yeah it's
awesome for for these realtime processes
because it doesn't explode in memory so
these kind of things you can do
since we run a little bit long we have
time for one more quick
question uh yeah first but you happy to
come to me and ask for the questions
after the after the
talk so the question is whether it
already runs with web assembly um I
think
not so um the idea is also kind of to
have it more as a as a server side thing
to to really have this
processes um to to access data which
should be secured somehow but it would
be awesome also to kind of to to give
whatever could be given to the client
side yeah and in form of web assembly um
background is that um the the core
implementation of the notebook is in
Julia and Julia uses a lot of just in
time compilation and web assembly is not
yet there with code Generation Um and
while this is in process as I know it
yeah it's not that that easily possible
to transfer this to web assembly yet
because of this dependency on code
Generation Um there are efforts but I
guess it t takes a bit more time so
python world is easier to get to code
assembly because you don't have this um
just in time
compilation but the Julia side depends
heavily on on jit compilation and there
it's bit difficult more difficult so I
think answer is not and I guess not in
in two years yeah thank you okay thanks
everyone also for your questions thank
you very much for a nice talk um you
also have a talk I think in the startup
track later in this morning right so if
you want to join that you can go there
as well um and then we'll close with
another big round of applause thank you
so
[Applause]
[Music]
much
am